welcome back let's get more than on your
questions about the crisis after last
week's mini budget turned ounces from
our panel of experts let me introduce
them they are Gemma Godfrey who is a
personal finance expert welcome Gemma
Sonia matharu who's a mortgage broker
and Mentor with the mortgage Mum hi
there Sonia and Yale self in Who's chief
Economist at KPMG one of the big four
accountancy companies of course so very
good to see you yo well now let's uh
kick off then lots of questions coming
in a wide variety of aspects of this
economic crisis that we seem to be
facing and this first one big picture
stuff I suppose and it's looking for an
instant solution it's from Spencer who
says if the chancellor were to do a
u-turn on his mini budget would that fix
the current issues wipe it from the
record I suppose Yale self in um that
would mean I mean it's not just the
additional rate tax cut is it it's the
basic rate cut stamp Duty Cuts National
Insurance corporation tax there was a
lot in there
yes absolutely I mean I guess it's very
unlikely to happen and also probably one
of the key issues that we're having in
the moment with the market is that they
lost confidence in the chancellor and in
the direction that the new government is
trying to take so a U-turn would not
necessarily fix it because we do have
major project problems in the UK at the
moment short term trying to protect at
least those very vulnerable households
that are affected particularly badly by
the higher energy prices but also the
longer term problems with weaker growth
so we do need action and just a U-turn
would not really solve it well would a
halfway house be another statement of
clarification from the chancellor and
the thing that was missing on Friday
which was the accompanying Judgment of
The Office Independent office for Budget
responsibility which the markets didn't
seem to like and that's really about how
you're going to pay for it all
yeah absolutely that was certainly
missing
um but also beyond that we we probably
needed a little bit more clarity as to
how the chancellor was planning to reach
the 2.5 growth that would hopefully pay
for quite a lot of it so it wasn't
really clear how that would happen just
by cutting taxes it's unlikely to to
make it happen and therefore markets
weren't really believing the plan so
there need to be more clarity on that as
well well that is the big picture let's
get now into some of the detail and some
of the questions coming from our viewers
and listeners this from Mazin asking
will we see a collapse amongst the
mortgage providers what do you think
Sonia because of course we've seen so
many mortgage providers well stop
lending and you know that's what they're
around to do
yes so what we're seeing at the moment
is a pause in the market so lenders have
taken um a step back just um reflecting
on um obviously what's been happening
and they're working really hard behind
the scenes to get themselves back on the
markets there's just a few decisions
that obviously need to be made and it's
not a collapse
um they are not going under or anything
like that they are simply just taking a
moment to reflect and review things and
then they are putting clouds into place
to come back onto the market now we have
seen um a lot of lenders obviously pull
out this week
um but you know even just today I'm
speaking to some of them and they're
saying that they'll it's likely they'll
they'll be back on the market by the end
of this week which is okay yeah I mean
what we know Sonia is is that they'll be
back with much higher rates and that
further down the line could lead to
defaults and then that puts the pressure
on the mortgage providers they're not
going paid back
yes yeah and I guess it depends on where
you are with your mortgage at the moment
of course you know if you've got a you
know a fixed rate mortgage
um then you know it depends on where you
are in that fixed rate but you're you
know your monthly payments have been
fixed for a set period of time so you
won't be affected by that but of course
if you are coming up to a remortgage
soon you may be
um it is likely that your monthly
payments will be higher than what you
have been used to paying okay another
specific question from Tommy uh maybe
you could dance to this first Gemma here
it is I recently received some money
should I use it to pay off my student
loan put it towards my fixed rate
mortgage or invest it well that's a
quite a nice position to be in so
Tommy's got some money what should he do
with it
I mean that's a fantastic position to be
in to be able to try and decide where to
allocate the money and interestingly
paying off student debt is something
that keeps coming up
um The Challenge there is actually is
that it really should come and lower
down the pecking order so one of the
most important things to be able to do
is to
um make sure that you are saving for a
rainy day fund to make sure that you're
paying towards your pension before
student loans because obviously there's
a certain element of debt forgiveness so
after a certain amount of time of 30
years or so if you haven't paid back all
your student loaner gets written off and
so if you at this stage decide to
overpay on your student loan and let's
say come into financial difficulty later
you can't go backwards in terms of your
fixed rate mortgage and obviously people
are concerned about mortgages because I
mean there are over 2 million households
who within the next two years are going
to come to the end of a fixed rate and I
don't think we got that detail from the
question but if someone's concerned
about coming towards the end of a fixed
rate mortgage then you know being able
to try and reduce that debt obviously
could help them longer term because it
is going to be getting more expensive
when they um mortgage but of course if
when we're talking about at a fixed rate
it's a fixed rate and it's very very low
um then paying that off is going to only
see you marginally improve your
situation whereas putting your money
towards um you know future growth could
potentially do better but again caveats
there are at the moment even though
we're seeing interest rates rise we're
seeing interest rates rise on debt not
necessarily on savings accounts
um and so because they're so low it's
still a challenging time in that respect
I think we get into that with another of
the questions they've got another very
quick question for you Gemma and I think
the answer is going to be a three letter
word beginning with why are my premium
bonds safe ask Lucy
um yes so that would be the simple
answer it's that by the treasury rather
than a bank
um so it should be safe I mean never say
never but you know it should be safe the
British government hasn't defaulted if
the British government's defaulting we
have a few other massive problems that
are there and the risk that you take so
the word there was safe the risk you
take was something like premium bonds is
on the return you're getting because
they don't always give Market leading
returns but generally in terms of
savings in general
um there's a certain limit you know 85
000 pounds that should be covered by the
financial services compensation scheme
when it comes to premium bonds again
backed by the treasury hopefully your
Capital will be protected okay yeah we'd
be in a really bad State yes if that was
not the case uh one on mortgages uh so
Sonia my fixed term mortgage runs out
next year I'm worried about the interest
rate Rising so should I pay to exit
early and get a five-year fixed term now
or can I extend my current fixed period
that from James so runs out next year
the fixed term
okay yeah so it honestly it depends upon
your personal circumstances and your
financial standing
um if this is something you are
considering I would really strongly
advise that you seek professional
um advice from a qualified broker
because there are numerous factors to
consider here such as early repayment
charges and what you don't want to do is
um make costly decisions
um from Fear so make sure you speak to
somebody and you know get
um gets all the advice and all the
information so that you can make an
informed decision moving forward that's
going to be really suitable to you
um that yeah it's it's what is a tricky
one to ask without knowing you know the
full personal details but yeah seek
advice and make sure that you you get
um you know the right outcome for you
yeah and do those costings because there
always are exit penalties aren't there
for me exactly a fixed rate
um this is about I suppose is partly our
next question about what was going on
today Aunt Sylvan can you deal with this
what is the risk to pension pots now I
think for a lot of people this
intervention by the bank of England came
from a clear blue sky in an area that I
mean even for those that pay attention
to the markets a run Dynamic whatever
that may be what was going on our
pension pots safe
it means the problem was with the yields
the yields weren't going very high and
that put some pressure on on pensions
because because of the costs involved in
their exposure but um what the bank of
England did was essentially to intervene
and call to cause the long-term yields
to fall quite effectively in fact so so
I'd say we are in a better position and
and it probably prevented the more major
term one in Market at this stage but but
ultimately I'd say
Investments can go up and down the
Investments you have in a pension the
value of it can go up and down and this
is not something that the bank of
England can ultimately guarantee
and here's uh thanks for that here's a
question then about I suppose the the
push me pull you nature of governments
policy and Bank of England actions of
course as well listen Simon
um asks this Sonia how are tax cuts
supposed to put more money in our
pockets if the mortgage rate is also
going up swings and roundabouts
yeah it really is swings around about
um especially a lot of people at the
moment are um you know experience
increase costs from all angles you know
not only interest rates are going up and
we've got also the cost of living as
well and you know it's it's it is a
difficult time for for many
um but you know what I would want to um
the message I would want to put out
there is that there is help and
sometimes as well you know so you can
sit there and really worry about things
but there are also like answers out
there and solutions really so again it
goes back to what I said earlier is
making sure that you speak professional
advice
um you know from somebody who can really
sit there and help you through there's
always things that can be done
um I think at the moment a lot of people
are seeing just the cost of everything
going up and thinking how can I afford
this I'm not going to be able to support
my house soon and someone's going to
take it away from me but there is a lot
of things that can happen between
um you know a lot of things that can
happen before that does so just make
sure you speak to somebody if you are
concerned at all because there is help
out there for you that's good to hear um
where is the time going we're nearly out
of it anyway
um here's a big question Gemma maybe you
hear from Yale on this as well Gemma why
is the drop in the pound a bad thing
well it isn't necessarily is it if you
run a business and you um export to the
United States and things like that
um exactly if you if you if the pound
gets cheaper then obviously the value of
our exports get more competitive we
still earn the same amount of pounds but
against a more locally you know driven
companies our exports are better however
we're in the UK and the problem with
having a weaker currency is that the
goods that we import and we import a lot
of food and we import a lot of fuel as
well so it means that right now when
we're really battling a cost of living
crisis with every all the prices of
everything you know across the board
really you know going up having a weaker
currency so that anything else we get
externally and having that being driven
much much higher much more expensive is
obviously going to cause a lot more pain
longer term
well I'm afraid we are totally out of
time Gemma thank you very much indeed
Sonia very good to see you Yale thank
you all for your expert input and uh
we'll be back with you uh very soon uh
coming up we'll have more of your
questions on the situation including
those on saving accounts and the value
of the pound
[Music]
welcome back to this uh question and
answer section on the economic turmoiler
let's get back to the questions that
you've been sending in and I think you
know my expert panel by now this is
coming from Max Max asks I have some
money in a help to buy account should I
keep it there or move it Gemma what is a
help to buy accounts I mean clearly it's
um to do with housing
yeah I mean it is it's it's government
support that will contribute towards
um the ability for you to be able to
save towards a property
um but the the I think the challenge is
um around the help to buy scheme is of
course the limited time that that's left
available on it
um and of course in a market like this
you know with properties getting more
and more expensive you know people are
going to need a lot more support
um out there and mortgages getting less
available and of course having less
choice in the marketplace we saw 300
mortgage deals pulled yesterday alone so
I think there's a lot of different
moving factors there which will
determine whether a scheme like that
will be appropriate okay another one on
uh mortgages uh Sonia after years of
saving I'm almost in a position to buy a
house where does this imminent rise in
interest rates leave first-time buyers
and younger people looking to buy a home
that from t k so yes an imminent rise in
interest rates but also in the budget
there was quite a large increase in the
exemption from stamp Duty wasn't there
for first-time buyers yeah
yes absolutely
um you're right so you know they are
going to benefit from those um stamp
Duty changes there but
to the question
um my advice really would be again to
speak to a professional speak to a
mortgage broker and see what your
potential mortgage could look like for
you because it's really scary listening
to everything that's going on at the
moment and also making it relative to
you so I think it's really important to
get professional advice and guidance
speak to somebody who can sit down with
you and talk through what you know this
mortgage could look like for you what it
could look like on a monthly
um on a monthly basis as well with those
monthly payments and then once you've
got this um like indicative information
you can make an informed decision and
then also start to look at it a bit
holistically as well so can you afford
those monthly payments because obviously
you know as a mortgage broker and
lenders that you there's a audibility
calculations so what we could say is
Affordable as well but it has to feel
right um for you
um also what um with my lifestyle look
like if I was to you know proceed with
this now and all of these kinds of
things are very important like I don't
think we should ignore our gut feelings
and our personal things when we come
when it comes to this like it's a very
emotional process and a very emotional
purchase
um so you know those factors are
important so don't base your decisions
solely on the market or also what your
friends and family are doing because
it's got to be what's right for you
um so yeah that would be my advice okay
just at the moment thank you for that
let's uh concentrate on stock markets
here we've got a question from Stuart
simply asking how will this affect my
shares yeah
um we've seen stock markets of course
before well they've been falling over
most of the year but I mean no collapse
no great kind of Crash yet
well I mean it is very difficult to
predict we are seeing High volatility we
also potentially depending on how this
evolves we could see
um a stronger weakness in in the actual
economy and that would lead into
potentially weaker
um stock market But ultimately you need
we need to understand also that there's
actually there's a lot of a lot of
companies that are quoted on the stock
markets that had that export quite a lot
um especially the larger multinationals
and and a weaker pound favors them
um because they have quite a lot of
earnings that are denominated in in
other currencies
um so so ultimately it's not that
clear-cut
so there are opportunities out there
depending where which part of the world
you put your money in
yeah no definitely I mean the global
economy overall is slow and we've just
launched our global economic Outlook
report and it's not looking great across
many
um countries but there's some areas
where there's more weakness than others
there's some there's some countries that
we would expect to be a little bit more
resilient in the next year
okay well following on from that is
Brian's question asking where is my
money safest Investments or savings by
that by Investments I suspect Brian
means that the stock market shares or or
cash savings what do you think Gemma I
mean interest rates are going up
presumably Savers will see better rates
eventually but you're always told aren't
you people like you always say that for
the longer term you're better invested
in stocks and shares because of
dividends
okay so yeah it's really important Also
to clarify the word safe you know where
are you safest because on the one hand
if you really you know leave your money
under the mattress staying in cash is
the safest thing because you've got a
limited loss but in another respect
you're guaranteed to be worse off
because of inflation your money isn't
going as far as it used to
um so then you go to cash savings
accounts that you know can offer you a
bit of interest
um in terms of a return on your money so
that's you know a little bit better
still but again that interest usually
doesn't keep up with the rising cost of
living and absolutely as you said there
is investing with investing does come
risk so yeah of course there are some
things that will pay you dividends but
just in general when it comes to
investing you're also almost guaranteed
to see a dip along the way which is why
the best uh the most you know the most
important thing there is to make sure
you have enough cash savings to start
with an emergency fund and then if you
look at investing be able to invest for
at least three to five years and really
in line with how comfortable you are at
seeing it dip along the way as well and
just a quick thought on that then yeah I
mean another aspect of fall in share
prices and certainly a fall in the value
of the pound is is that the UK companies
become cheaper to International
predators
yeah not just UK companies UK assets
more broadly
um so we could potentially
um see stronger FDI and stronger
investment for Android investment
although that tends to be
um the the with a fairly longer time lag
um in that sense
well listen we are fully out of time now
thank you all once again yourself in
Sonya matharu Gemma Godfrey very good to
tap your brains there thank you very
much indeed
and you are of course watching Sky News
Tonight coming up at eight o'clock we'll
have all the very latest on the crisis
in the markets that's after the
government's Budget on Friday and
today's unexpected intervention by the
bank of England we'll have all the
analysis
foreign
[Music]